hello hello I'm just thinking about your
property that you've just bought on to
come trillion is it still for sale oh
just yeah I've just seen it come up so
um that's great would it be okay maybe
ask a few questions about the about the
house okay so I'm looking at the
pictures it looks I can't really see too
clearly but it looks like it's in
reasonable condition but I just wondered
doesn't it need work or is the condition
good it looks nice and like I see he's
got a garden
it's got garden everything that's nice
[Music]
excellent and there's no problems no no
I'm not I'm not from address field I'm
based in Sheffield so not too far yeah
so um yeah are you are you living in it
are you or what's your so how much how
much how much rent we getting for if you
don't mind me asking yeah yeah yeah it's
extra it is extra nice yeah
yeah cuz I've got I've got quite a lot
of properties I'm an honour landlord so
a lot of landlords are looking to sell
at the moment with the new tax changes
and bricks it and everything like that
but I'm just looking at I'm looking
again a few more like this I mean this
is on four is it sixty sixty four sixty
five thousand was it okay well I know
the I know the area reasonably well I
know it's in Huddersfield what's the
whereabouts is it because I've not got
an exact address on here okay okay no
that's right that's right well okay I
mean what I was thinking is I mean we
may be are you arranging are you doing
viewings on the property or an agent
okay yeah I mean probably just just to
sort of save time and things like that
what I usually do is if I can kind of
maybe just have a look do some
comparables and give you an idea of what
my offer would likely to be but it would
be definitely more than 60,000 because
I'm not one of those investors that
offers really cheeky offers because I
don't like to do that so no it's a waste
it so I so I don't like to waste time
because I think time is time is money
right yeah what sort of sort of yeah
yeah that makes sense I mean what what
what what sort of I hope you don't mind
me asking like a couple of financial
questions about the house so that I can
maybe give you an offer perhaps Thanks
what watch them what I was gonna ask
what the reason for selling it was and
not renting out and though what's the
[Music]
[Music]
yeah now that makes sense if the
property is mortgageable can you get
have you got a mortgage on the property
at the moment or is it okay that's fine
because yeah yeah yeah yeah and also
some of the properties that I buy I do
like a rent to buy scheme where I'll pay
a monthly guaranteed rent with then a
delayed completion at the end of the
agreement I don't know ever that's
something that you'd consider in your
situation or not for instance to give
you an example to give enough to
obviously see the property but if you
could if you're saying that the rent
would be four hundred pounds and then
obviously you've got to you know you've
got to pay for maintenance and
management and everything like that so
you might be left with two or three
hundred pounds profit afterwards what we
what we do is we would say we can give
you maybe two hundred pounds or two
hundred and fifty pounds a month
guaranteed rent
costs and then we'll buy the property
for say seventy thousand pounds but
we'll buy in a few years to give the
market chance to recover and that's the
sort of structure of the of the of the
deal so would that be something you'd be
open to yeah of course
yeah sure I understand yeah okay well
exactly yeah yeah so we could either
there's two ways you could do it we
could even set a price now in size for
instance seventy thousand pounds and
give the market chance to recover or we
could we could we could say a percentage
of what its gonna buy depending on what
you know you felt more comfortable with
so we could just set an agreed figure
and say in in say three years time we'll
buy it for 70 and we'll give you two
hundred and fifty pounds per month
guaranteed until the end of the three
years but of course it's all negotiable
no in the same way as you do you have to
think about it and see what the response
was from the advert I would of course
have to see the property and and things
like that I'm not making you an official
offer I'm just letting you know the the
the outline of what it could look like
that make sense
yeah yeah okay yeah that sounds like a
good plan that sounds like a good plan
but what I'll do then do you want me to
I mean there's a few options we could do
now I could leave it leave it for the
time being and then touch base with you
in a few days or a few weeks or whatever
or well I could a range of viewing or I
mean it just depends on what on what you
want to do okay yeah
yeah so what I'll say I'll leave you
I'll leave my number with you as well so
if you if you want to give me a call you
can and then perhaps we'll touch base it
is it is I think I think I can get you
on on gumtree
that's no problem thank you so much for
your time and I hope you sell it and if
not then we can live a chat Cheers bye
now bye
I mean that's my first call